-Our first guest tonight is a
very funny comedian and actor
you know from
"The King of Staten Island"
and "Saturday Night Live."
He stars in the new
animated series
"The Freak Brothers,"
which is streaming exclusively
on Tubi November 14th.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Pete Davidson,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Hello.
-It's nice to see you.
-Good to see you, too.
-This --
I was going to say thanks --
You know, you were just down
the hall, but you actually --
This is very on-brand
for Pete Davidson.
We were worried you weren't
gonna make it here on time
'cause you were stuck in traffic
on the Verrazzano Bridge.
-Yes. 30 minutes ago,
I was on the Verrazzano Bridge.
-This is very impressive
that you made it.
And I can't thank you enough.
-Oh, that's -- You know,
I'm excited to be here.
Thanks for having me.
-I want to address something.
I feel like I want to confirm
if it's real...
-Okay.
-...or a rumor.
You've been reading a lot
about it in the press.
-Yeah, you know,
I've been wanting to talk
about this because --
-Thank you.
We appreciate you doing it here.
-There's a lot of people
I walk by.
People are, like, whispering,
and, you know,
making eyes at me.
And, you know, but it is true --
I do have a show on Tubi
coming out.
-Tubi.
-Yeah.
-The Tubi.
A lot of people are shocked
I could get on a show like Tubi.
-Yeah. But it's a real --
-It's a real thing. Tubi. Yeah.
-Yeah. That's exciting.
-Yes. Thank you.
-And, you know, you are --
'cause you do a lot of stand-up.
Obviously, we know
from you "SNL," as well.
-Yeah.
-First time doing animated.
-Yes.
-It seems like a scam.
-It's a dream.
You just get to sit --
You go --
I got to do it in my closet.
-Yeah.
-Now, was it the closet
because of the pandemic or...?
-No, I just requested it.
That was -- Yeah.
No, it was during the pandemic,
and they called.
And they were like,
"Would you like to do a cartoon
with Woody Harrelson,
John Goodman,
Tiffany Haddish, La La Anthony,
Adam DeVine,
and Blake Anderson?"
I was like, "Yeah."
I was like, "What's the --
What's the premise?""
They're like, "You're a pothead
that smokes weed all the time."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Yeah. For sure.
Absolutely. Yeah."
-As an actor,
you've always said to me
you want to stretch.
-Yeah, I need to stretch
my legs a little bit.
-Yeah.
-You want to challenge yourself
to do different things.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-That is really
an all-star cast.
-Yeah.
-You have to tell us --
I think you are --
you are the middle
of these three gentlemen, right?
-Yes, that is me.
-Yeah.
-That is Phineas Freakers.
-He is, you know,
the kind of nerdy --
He thinks he's really smart,
leader of the Freak Brothers.
-Yeah.
-And that is me.
-Now, this kind of has the style
that plays into this premise,
because this --
You guys are '60s stoners...
-Right.
-...who come
to the modern times.
It's a very high-concept
stoner cartoon.
-You know, everybody is into,
like, "Tenet" and [bleep].
But this is --
-Can we talk about that?
Everybody's into "Tenet."
-"Tenet" and [bleep].
But listen.
This -- This story
really spoke to me.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause that's the thing.
The two things --
When you answer the phone,
you want to be challenged
in the part...
-Yes, challenged.
-...and the script
has to speak to you.
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-And they were like --
The story is...
that these three gentlemen
smoke a mega doobie
in 1969.
And they wake up in 2021.
-There you go. And --
-So you know what?
So enough about "Tenet."
-Yeah.
-We get it.
-You can only imagine
what these fellas get into.
-And this is -- this is --
-That's Tiffany Haddish.
-Yeah.
-For real?
-Yeah, no, for real.
-She is a talking cat.
-Who's sort of your guide.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, she's the best.
-Do you find when you're
in the closet recording...
[ Laughter ]
Do you find, like --
They're listening in real time
or do you record it
and send it off?
-They're there with you,
which is very --
-Not in the closet with you.
-No, they're not
in the closet with me.
But my --
[ Laughter ]
They watch you do it,
which is always weird,
because you'll do, like --
You're screaming in your closet.
-Yeah.
-And then they'll be like,
"Yeah, that was really good.
Let's do it again
and in a completely different
other way
that wasn't like what you did."
But we had fun doing it.
It was just something really
nice to do during the pandemic.
-I am a huge fan of your mom...
-Yes.
-...who is one of the
sweetest ladies in the world.
-Me, as well.
Amy Davidson. Good lady.
-Now, is Amy --
During this time,
were you and Amy
under the same roof?
Was she there when you would,
like, skulk off to the closet?
And did she believe you
when you told her
you were doing a cartoon?
-Yeah. I'm just like --
We did live together
for like a good two years,
and she was
a pretty great roommate.
-Yeah. How would you --
What do you think
she would say
about you as a roommate?
-I think she would just be like,
"That kid jerks off a lot."
Like...like...
[ Laughter ]
-I will say, I do believe this.
If a mom said it, I do think
they wouldn't say your name.
They'd say "that kid."
-"That kid."
-They'd be like,
"Pete's on 'SNL.'
Pete's in the movies.
Pete's got a show on Tubi.
That kid jerks off a lot."
-"That kid jerks off a lot."
Yeah. No. But we had
a really good situation.
It was really -- It was like --
We got really close
and really tight. I enjoyed it.
-That's really awesome.
-Yeah.
-Does she -- What --
Of your stuff,
what does she like the most?
I mean, she must have liked
the fact
that you did a film
in Staten Island.
-Yeah, I think she's just happy
I'm not, like, selling crack
under the bridge.
You know, because, like,
that's definitely my calling.
So, yeah, she's just --
she's pleased with anything.
But every once in a while,
she is --
You can tell
she's still a little unsure
of how it's gonna go,
as am I every day.
But the other day,
she was just like,
"The garbage man's test
is coming up this week."
She goes, "It's a lovely job.
You work for the city.
You get a uniform."
[ Laughter ]
-You were like,
"I've got a show on Tubi!"
-On Tubi, dude. Tubin' it up.